- How many of the things
that you're gonna say tonight
are gonna be exaggerations and lies?
- So how emotionally closed off are you?
- What's the exact
relationship with your mother?
- So are you good with money?
- Is it too early in this
date to ask what your deal is?
- So really, when's the last
time you sent a dick pic?
- Do you actually find me funny
or are you just trying to sleep with me?
- How fragile would you
say your masculinity is?
- So, how drunk are we getting tonight?
- How drunk can I get before
it's a turnoff for you?
- Are you hung up on any exes?
- Was your ex crazy or
were you an asshole?
- Oh my gosh.
Are we having sex tonight?
- That laugh I did earlier.
Endearing or annoying?
- Wait, wait. So how
accurate would you say
your dating profile is to your real life?
- Can you give me some examples
so I know you're smart?
- (laughs) That's so funny.
Is your apartment creepy?
- This is going so great.
How many dates have
you been on this month?
- 10?
15?
30?
- How much baggage of mine
are you willing to deal with?
- Why is every friend you mention female?
- So, how much porn do you watch?
- Do you always brag like
this or are you just nervous?
- Earlier you said I
looked hot in this dress.
Did you mean like good hot,
or slutty hot,
or were you just being polite?
- Is your mother awful?
- You seem like such a good guy.
Is this all bullshit?
- I might have to fart right now.
How good is your sense of smell?
- Oh, so you're gonna call me?
When, exactly?
- How quickly are you looking
to make me your girlfriend?
I don't want it too quick.
But I don't want it too slow, either.
- I love your beard.
How hairy is your back?
- If I have sex with you tonight,
are you going to judge me?
- This is so great.
Now, how are you going
to summarize this date
to your friends?
- [Man] We'll go cliff jumping.
We'll check out the
waterfalls. It'll be great.
- That sounds amazing.
How do you feel about kids?
- This was really, really fun.
Can you give me a general sum up
of what I talked about tonight?
I just want to make
sure you were listening.